Adam, you are on stage. Hello. Hello.
Hello. You a Muslim? Yeah. Yeah. What's
up? What's up, man? What's up, man? How
do you solve this Islamic dilemma, bro?
Can you repeat your argument, please?
All right. The Quran confirms the Bible.
But it confirms the Bible while it also
contradicts the Bible. So, since it
confirms the Bible, the Bible is true.
Since the Quran contradicts the Bible,
that means that the Quran is false. If
the Bible is false and and corrupted,
then the Quran is still false because it
is confirming a false corrupted book. So
either way you go, if the Bible is true
like the Quran says, then the Quran is
false because it contradicts it. If the
Bible is false and corrupted like
Muslims say, then the Quran is still
false for confirming a false corrupted
book. That's the dilemma. So, I think
you're stretching it when it's saying
it's confirming because you totally
neglected the last part of the verse cuz
Oh, with them. Yeah, you're right. I
meant to say with them. I I forgot to I
left that out. My bad. Confirming what
is with them. What they have in their
possession. My bad. Thanks for
correcting me. Okay. Can you wait for me
till I pull up the verse? Wait. Sure.
Chapter 2, verse 41. Oh, okay.
So you you ignored the last part when it
confirms the scripture of Did you say
548 or I said chapter 2 verse 41? Oh,
okay. My bad. Wait. Shoot up.
[Music]
So this is talking about the the the
original revelation that was revealed to
the prophets. Did the did it exist in
Muhammad's time? I don't really know.
Well, it says it's with them, right?
According to that verse, it says they
have it. Yeah. So, it did exist. They
had the authentic scriptures revealed to
the prophets. They had it in their
possession. And the Quran says that what
they have is true. It confirms it. Yeah.
It doesn't say that. It confirms it. Cuz
in another verse, it Well, wait. Don't
go to another verse. You're saying it
doesn't say that. If Stay in that verse
right there, and then we can move on to
something else. But according to that
verse that you're looking at, 241, it
literally says it's confirming what is
with them. Right. Right. 241. Yeah. It
confirms the truth contained in it. No,
it doesn't say that. It says that it's
confirming what is with them, right? It
doesn't say it's confirming the truth in
them. It's conf confirming the good
part. It says very blatantly, very
clearly confirming what is with them.
Right. Hold on. Wait. Okay. Take your
time.
You got it. So I I still think that uh
some had the original form but it was it
was still altered after they got it. I
got you. So by the time Muhammad comes
around it's altered at that point right?
No not by the time but Oh so was it was
it altered before Muhammad's time or
after? Are you typing? No. This is my
brother beside me. Oh is the brother
typing? Yeah. Okay. Yeah, he's helping
me. That's good. That's good. That's all
right. That's good. Tell the brother I
said hi. I think I He said hi. He said I
back. He's shy. It's all right. So,
chapter 2, verse 41. Can Can you just
confirm with me that it does say
confirming what is with them, right?
Yes. Awesome. Now, was the scriptures
corrupted at this time or were they
fully intact? They were corrupted. All
right. So since the scriptures were
corrupted, you're telling me that the
Quran is confirming corrupted books,
right? I I still like I I have a gap
that I didn't find that I'm trying to
There's There's no way out of this one,
brother. There's no there's no gap you
can squeeze out of this one, dude. This
is this is troubling. Now, I know Yeah,
that that that's another part somebody
mentioned chapter 6 verse 115. That's
another part of the dilemma because
obviously the Quran says that none can
change the words of Allah. Muslims are
telling us actually no people can change
the words of Allah and that's fine. You
know, we just we allow the Muslims to
hold their position that they've been
corrupted and show them how bad of a
position that puts Allah in and the
Quran. It really it really puts you guys
in a bad position saying that the
scriptures are corrupted. It's really
you make the Quran look silly. So I
think when it says and believe in what I
have sent down it it refers to the
literal word of gods that doesn't
change. The literal word of God that
doesn't change in his books. Right.
Yeah. That confirm the the scriptures
that contain his original words in it.
Right. But you're saying that those
books were changed. Yeah, they were
changed but his words weren't. Yeah,
they were. You just said I don't I'm
confused. The original scriptures are
boom. They here. Right. You have the
original scriptures and then these
original scriptures get altered, right?
Yeah. So people do change the original
words of Allah. They do not change the
literal words of Allah, but they change
the words that are contained in the
scripture. So the scriptures can be
changed. You're you're saying the
scriptures are not Allah's actual words.
No. So when God says something and it is
revealed in a scripture, then people
change the scripture. It is not God's
word anymore, right? They changed God's
word. Yeah, but not Okay. Yeah, they
changed. Yes. All right. So, I just want
to make sure I jot that down. So, you're
saying that the scriptures um are not
Allah's words. Is that correct? No. So,
the original scriptures that Allah has
sent down that has revealed to the that
have revealed to the prophet Mhm. are
not altered. But when people have
received it, they altered the
scriptures. Right. So they altered
Allah's words when they got them. Yes.
So Allah's words can be altered. Yes.
But not in the literal sense. That's
what I mean. Okay. If Allah says if
Allah says the sky is blue. Yes. And he
sends down a scripture saying that the
sky is blue. Yeah. The sky is blue. Then
people you come and you get that
scripture and you change it to say the
sky is pink. Did you change Allah's
literal words? Yes, but I made it look
like it was Allah's words. Right. So you
they're not Allah's words, right? So
Allah's
words is I got you. So Allah's literal
words can be changed to make it look
like it's his words when it's really
not. Yes. So Allah's words can be
changed. All right. I don't uh I don't
understand if you're like getting it in
the literal sense or like you know what?
How about let's let's let's leave that
alone for a second. Let's focus on your
idea that the scriptures were corrupted.
Okay, let's let's let's leave that part.
Let's leave this alone. The scriptures
are corrupted by the time Muhammad is
already reciting the Quran to the Jews
and Christians and other people. Right?
The scriptures have already been altered
right by the time. Okay. So the
scriptures that is with the Jews and
Christians are altered. They're
corrupted. They're not reliable. The
Quran then comes and says that it is
confirming what is with them, what they
have. Well, what's the verse, brother?
Come on. Where where have you been at?
We No, cuz there there are multiple
verses. I want to like check. Chapter 2
verse 41. I've only mentioned one so
far. So when when it says that we have
sent down. Okay, let me uh I'm getting
lost. Wait. Okay. And when it says and
believe in what I have sent down, it
means believe in the Quran, right?
What's been sent down is the Quran.
Confirming that which is with you. Yeah.
So the Quran is confirming that which is
with you. What they have? Yes. You're
telling me that you're talking about the
Quran now? No, no, no. The Quran is the
thing that is doing the confirming. Yes.
Confirming something else, which is the
previous scriptures, right? Yes. All
right. So, the previous scriptures is
with the people. They have it. It's with
them. But it's corrupted according to
you, right? Yes. So, this means that the
Quran is sent down confirming corrupted
and altered scripture. No. When it says,
"And believe in what I have sent down,"
it is referring to the original
revelations that were were revealed to
the prophets that were before the Quran.
Walk through this with me. You can see
You can see the You can You can see the
screen, right? You see the screen? Yes.
Walk through this with me. Believe in
what I have sent down. That's the Quran.
So, believe in the Quran, right? Yes.
Confirming that which is already with
you. So the Quran is coming confirming
some scriptures that already exist in
the possession of the people of the
book. Right. They have these scriptures.
Yes. Right. Okay. So it's confirming
these scriptures that they have. What do
they have? Do they have the original or
do they have a corrupted version? I
think I'm going to I'm going to make a
stop here. Uh, I think this verse is
talking about the Quran, not the other
scriptures. Lord have mercy. Where's
your brother? Oh, he's gone. Can you
bring him back? Cuz I don't know. I at
one at one time you're talking about the
Quran being confir confirming the other
scriptures and then you're talking about
other scriptures being confirmed by the
Quran. Yeah. I don't I don't I don't
want to be rude to you, man. You haven't
been rude. You've been polite here. I
don't want to be rude, but it it sounds
like like man, this is this is really
simple, bro. This isn't this verse is
talking about the the Quran being
confirmed. It's not talking about the
Quran being confirmed, my friend. Adam.
Adam, I I walked through this with you.
I don't I don't know how else to teach
this to you. I I I don't know what else
to do. I don't know how to reach you,
man. The Look, I'm going to try one more
time and then if you can't get this, I
you know, you know, I'll let you go.
Believe in what I have sent down. What
is that? The Quran. What is the Quran
doing? It is confirming itself. But the
Quran Okay. I can't take care,
bro.
Shoot.
Oh, how do I reach these
kids? Oh, man. Good googlym. Is that Is
that worth writing down? Y'all let me
know, man. I I That might be. Is that
worth writing down, ladies and gents?
What do y'all think? Yes. Yes. Wifey
votes yes as well. All right, this is
going in the books. 100. Remember this
time stamp, man. about an hour and four
minutes, an hour and three minutes. On
April 7th of the Islamic dilemma stream,
our friend Adam said that in chapter
2:41, the Quran is confirming itself. My
gosh, the Quran is confirming itself.
Adam, you can't make this up. And and
the thing is, he's a he's nice. He's a
nice guy, man. You know, you can't even
you can't talk bad about about you know,
somebody like that. He's nice. Just
probably honestly
genuinely doesn't get it or doesn't want
to get it. He was a nice guy though,